hey guys Ryan right here it's like a
thousand degrees in my apartment for
some reason air conditioners been on for
hours I don't know what's going on we're
gonna check out the trailer today
insidious chapter 3 the second trailer I
love the first insidious I even did
enjoy the second insidious I didn't
think it was as bad as everyone said it
was this one I think is a prequel
there's a actor in it that I know named
Ashton Moyo he plays the boyfriend of
the main girl he's cool he's cool huge
dick
huge big frightening images okay
[Music]
it's not gonna stay positive
[Music]
why
[Music]
that is so [ __ ] freaky
[Music]
this next is very dangerous
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
horror movies are the most interesting
experience cuz I get jacked to see them
and then just from watching a trailer
I'm like why the [ __ ] am I gonna put
myself through this this looks
terrifying you know I like the practical
effects they have going on
insidious okay one concern I have you
see there's part one and then part two
continuing with the same family and they
expanded the story you learn more
there's like a few twists and turns here
they link to the first one this one it's
a prequel and you know you got the I
forgot the dude's name beavis and
butthead and you got the old lady and
you know they're gonna survive because
it's an origin and they're in the first
two so you know they're gonna be okay
storyline looks a little cliche I feel
like the fear will be there I feel like
there's gonna be some good jump scares I
feel like there's gonna be terrifying
moments but at the same time I don't
feel that there's gonna be something
unique to really offer with this story
of insidious I liked how the first one
was like a haunting and then the second
one was kind of like kind of remind me
of The Shining like domestic violence
this one it feels like it's going closer
to the first one but I don't really see
anything different about it but it's
just a trailer I'm sure there's gonna be
some surprises here and there I mean the
guy who wrote the first two he's
directing this one as well I think
that's really interesting to be like
okay James Wan directed the first two
and now he's handing it off to the
writer to continue directing and I'm
interested mainly for that reason too to
see like will this be even crazier will
this go all out because he's not gonna
be limiting himself at all because he is
in full creative control now so that's
one of the main reasons I'm gonna check
it out regardless it's insidious so I'm
gonna give it a shot anyway anyway guys
thanks for signing that trailer was out
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the reel rejects and you
can follow the real rejects on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter and on a side note
the pornhub.com site don't worry about
it
it's just undergoing some routine
maintenance right now but it should be
back up and going in the next couple
hours